obama's economist larry summers slams
biden on inflation saying it doesn't
look so transitory page six if you want
to go there
uh
let me see over here okay so here we go
uh uh larry summers who was the
secretary of treasury under clinton and
directed the national economic council
under obama said on cnn that inflation
is going to be unavoidable for the near
future i think the odds
are that we're going to have inflation
of a kind we haven't seen in 30 years
which already happened until either the
fed takes some significant move with
respect to monetary policy which i think
what he said is increasing rates or
until there is some kind of accident
that disrupts the economic growth we are
enjoying what is he talking about
summers continued by pointing out that
he thinks the biden administration is
acting incorrectly and making the
situation worse i think the fed has made
a significant mistake in the approach
that is uh it's taken by doubling down
on massive fiscal stimulus we had at the
beginning of the year and really easy
monetary policy let me read this one
more time from the obama camp i'm going
to read this one more time folks if
you're listening to this the obama camp
you ready i think the fed has made a
significant mistake on the approach it's
taking by doubling down on massive
fiscal stimulus huh so he's saying
stimulus is not a good thing a massive
fiscal stimulus we had at the beginning
of the year
and with really easy monetary policy
aren't they trying to push the next two
three four trillion dollar the 1.75 yeah
they're trying to push the next one they
want more than 1.75 but okay so what are
your thoughts about what he's saying
here with inflation tom i'm going to go
to you first it just i mean
when you look at where the source is and
that's the most that's the thing it's
the most unbelievable thing and then i'm
looking at down the road because i don't
know how you can argue against inflation
right now it is coming it is coming in a
much much bigger way we've only seen the
beginning of it
what is this going to do to them next
year or in the 2022 elections right the
midterms so this just seeing this
bickering when they're but this is just
common sense you cannot argue against it
and i think for his credibility he can't
say anything but this because it makes
sense i think though that's why they're
not pushing for it though the 2022
middle midterm election that if they
increase the rates before then things
are going to slow down and it's going to
be worse they're
my guess would be they're banking on
rather let it roll through the midterm
elections and then kind of do damage
control on the back end as opposed to
try to limit it on the front end so so
here's here's a so can we all agree that
the face of the democratic party is
still obama would you agree who would
you say the face of democratic party as
far as he's still popular yes but would
you say here's the face like what he
says everybody follow so let me just
throw some names out there and you tell
me no no he's the ef hutton that's what
i'm saying okay cool so if he is the ef
hutton and he's the voice
do you think behind closed doors a
serious question folks i'm curious to
know what you say about this serious
question because i i had a big debate
with a conservative the other day he
wasn't too happy about my position on
obama okay where i feel obama is today
um here's a question with obama how
often do you think obama and biden speak
today
pretty regularly i'm going to say
infrequently i'm i'm going to say not
that free you're saying pretty regularly
that'd be my guess tell me what pretty
regularly means uh i'd say on a weekly
basis once a week time you agree with
that
sorry guy hell no yeah i don't think
he's looking for advice from boxing i
think it's every day
really hell no oh so you're saying how
often so how often do you think him and
obama speak christmas and birthdays
really you're going there i don't know
how do i what do you think do i think
obama is speaking to a lot of the people
in this i agree with that yes okay so
what do you think i think politically
obama's trying to distance himself from
joe biden so i think very very
infrequently
very very infrequently okay so okay if
that's the case do you think obama's
sitting here himself saying look
i don't want my legacy to be tied to joe
because i think joe's about to go to the
gutter and i don't want them to say my
policies did this because if biden goes
to the gutter and everybody says and joe
says i'm just following all the policies
that obama had
and obama's gonna be like wait a minute
you gotta stop saying that because i
don't want my policies to be your
policies because your policies are
really hurting everything that's going
on right now in america i don't want to
associate myself with you with this by
the way uh our body here to my right's
got a lowrider and he's got these
hydraulics
i'm not used to that
either the sea level shrunk or there's
something up with this chair
global warming no i think there's
something there's something here that's
very interesting warming of the globe
go ahead
it looks like two globes but anyway the
um you've got
in the obama administration
summers and geithner did a really good
job of taking the handoff from bush
it the economy didn't go off the cliff
they had 0809 they had things to deal
with they had tarp and i thought they
did a really good job of preventing just
carnage on the financial side in the
recovery stage and 09 and 10 were great
on the recovery stage after the crash of
oa and i think these guys are sensible
really sensible and i think they're also
thinking about their
legacy and i think in the democratic
party there's a bunch of things moving i
think they don't want joe to run again
next time i think they want to absolute
castrate any opportunity that there is
for that and i think that obama doesn't
want his legacy to be tarnished and i
honestly think that summers and geithner
really want and some are speaking here
but remember tim was always right next
to him i think they really
want things to be better and i think
he's pointing out look guys you can't go
further you can't and if there is you
say
that you're just waiting
because you want to you know wait to do
something for the economy so that you
don't get accused of making a mistake
going into the midterm i think you guys
are making a mistake with that action
and i think it's as simple
as simple as that and i think larry's
unafraid to speak i don't think it's a
hit piece i don't think he's been
unleashed to go after him i think he's
out there saying hey i did this job i i
was here in the middle of a crisis guys
i did not have eight years of peace and
prosperity do you think obama is moving
further and further and further to the
right
you think ever since obama from day one
of obama taking presidency to today do
you think gradually he's moving a little
bit more to the center
i'm asking a question it's either yes or
no i'm saying not necessarily i don't i
don't i think so i think so you don't
think necessarily you know i really like
it well okay but what is the upside for
him even commenting right now did
somebody reach out this is strategic he
did this for a reason and this is less
than one year into biden's term i really
try to go there okay
i think obama is disassociating himself
with biden to the point where he's going
to dictate who runs next so
this is not a coincidence this this gets
out there for a reason obama's still
young he's still very very relevant
right he might be the wizard of oz
pulling all the strings in the
background who knows and i'm trying to
think who who would be his hand-picked
is it michelle i don't know well that's
what i'm talking about i think they're
trying to castrate it they said it was
transitory it doesn't look so transitory
they're wrong that's what he's saying
you're wrong they said it was a few
specific factors doesn't look to be a
few specific factors he's saying again
they're wrong so how many times can he
say in a very polite political statement
wrong they're wrong they're wrong
it sounds like a republican saying that
that's exactly right you know it's so
bizarre that would be more inflammatory
if it was coming from the period and
this is his guy this guy he campaigned
for
so so so again going back to the
question do you think he's moving to the
center i think so i think he's moving
more to the center more towards the
center i think obama 08 put on a persona
that was more liberal than he really was
do you think obama i think it's come
back do you think obama 08 is aoc 2021
or do you think obama 08
is bill clinton 1996.
i'm hoping that's cool well clinton ran
to the center i think obama 08 he was a
little more he was a little more like
obamacare all that stuff affordable
healthcare okay what i'm going to
promise to you and all this but i think
that he's been unmasked
as a far more of a moderate yeah i mean
that happens when you make fifty hundred
million dollars right
because
when you when you get a tax bill end of
the year you gotta pay 6.8 million you
look at michelle and say you know what
babe this year listen maybe we got to
make that phone call to larry to say
listen we ain't going to 40 percent yeah
that's a good point you know pat a good
way to judge it is michelle you got my
own phone got my whole phone give me the
michelle give me a sale and give me an
old phone
i gotta call the irs
do i solve the irs on speed let's see
who he basically let's see who he
campaigns for in 2022 if he's out there
for aoc and omar and some of these
others because i don't think he'll do
that i agree i don't think he'll be able
to i don't think he that would ruin for
him that would i don't think no listen
bernie aoc squad
he is a very very smart guy whether you
like him agree with him it doesn't
matter you have to respect an opponent
that guy is a very very smart guy he
knows what he's doing he he's a he's a
your next 15 moves type of guy
knowing what he's got going on so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]